[music playing]
NARRATOR: New York City, 1922.
Two Columbia University
sociologists--
William Ogburn and
Dorothy Thomas--
publish a paper in the
"Academy of Political
Science Journal" entitled,
"Are Inventions Inevitable?"
In it, they cite 148 instances
of simultaneous inventions
where two or more individuals--
each operating without
knowledge of the other's work--
came up with the same
groundbreaking innovation
or theory at the same time.
[music playing]
JOHN BRANDENBURG: How is it that
people in different continents,
different cultures can come up
with the same idea at almost
exactly the same time?
And it's seen
throughout history.
GRAHAM PHILLIPS:
Albert Einstein says
that he came up with
the idea for relativity
in a few moments.
It suddenly came into his mind.
JOHN BRANDENBURG: Einstein's
discovery of relativity was
preceded almost simultaneously
by a theoretical physicist,
a Frenchman named Poincar .
DAVID CHILDRESS: You
have the radio being
developed by both Nikola
Tesla and Guglielmo Marconi
at the same time.
You have the
telephone also being
developed at the same time.
There's many incidences
in history like this.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: During World
War II, British engineer
Sir Frank Whittle, and
a German physicist--
Hans Von Ohain-- both
invented the first jet engine.
The designs were
strikingly similar.
And because they were serving
on different sides of the war,
neither had any knowledge
of the other's work.
There have been discoveries that
have shown up around the planet
at the exact same time.
People that aren't
connected, people that have
no influence upon each other.
And those are the things that
start to emerge simultaneously
around the planet.
GRAY SCOTT: Here's
the interesting thing,
this goes back to
the idea that we
find information
in the substrate
of the physical world.
It may just be that
every single discovery
that we ever wanted to
discover is already in the room
right now.
It isn't that the
information is not there.
It's that our brains
are not evolved
yet to see the information.
Now, not everybody is
on the same wavelength.
Not everybody is evolved
at the same rate.
That's also true.
So there are people
throughout history that
could access that information.
DAVID WILCOCK: This
effect has been documented
all the way back to the
time of the Renaissance
and the Reformation, things like
the discovery of the telescope,
the identification of the
colors in the rainbow,
the identification
of basic chemistry,
the Theory of Evolution.
Scientists try to explain.
And they think people have a
certain level of technology
at a certain time, and they
have the tools in front of them
to be able to make
breakthroughs.
That doesn't explain
why it happens
so precisely that in many cases,
it is literally simultaneous.
We have to look
at the possibility
that extraterrestrials
could be introducing ideas
into this information field.
Sort of as if something has
been uploaded into the cloud.
[music playing]